je comprends leur frustration ça me fait
sourire parce que la frustration c'est
que depuis plusieurs auditions on tourne
en rond on pose les mêmes questions
on a déjà les mêmes réponses on imagine
des zones d'ombré on imagine des
contradictions où on apporter des
réponses
aujourd'hui donc je vois bien que cette
saison 2 de la sphère ben et l'a voulue
par le sénat qui va transformer cette
affaire d'été en affaires d'automne
n'est en fin de compte qu'une
manipulation politique pour porter tort
au gouvernement parce que toutes ces
choses ont été dites
les choses maintenant les réponses ont
été apportées
j'ai assisté à l'audition dans son
intégralité j'ai vu la redondance de
questions par rapport à ce que j'avais
entendu avant l'été vous comprenez qu'il
continue de demeurer un flou sur la
fonction d'alexandre benalla on a
entendu les sénateurs dire eh bien vous
le voyez il avait par exemple un permis
de port d'armes car il avait une mission
de police
alors comment peut-on dire réaliser
qu'ils n'avaient aucune fonction de
sécurité d'abord d'abord vous dire que
l'elysée joue totalement la transparence
chacun des membres de l'isi qui sont
convoqués reviennent avec tout en toute
transparence devant la commission 2
rapport à ce que vous évoquez à
l'instant il réponses ont été très
clairs alexandre de dallas n'avait pas
de fonctions de police
il lui a été délivrée en fonction un
permis de port d'armé pas pour des
fonctions police et que ledit comme tel
et en plus ils ne portaient pas d'armes
dans les missions qui lui étaient
confiées par le pour les déplacements du
président donc non je crois qu'à chaque
fois on revient on a dit et vous des
mensonges sur sa rémunération sur
l'appartement
on a avancé des chiffres qui ne sont pas
vraies aujourd'hui une fois de plus le
chef de cabinet apporter des réponses
concordante avec celle de monsieur
strzoda et celle des autres demande de
l'elysée savait parler à l'instant d'une
instrumentalisation de la commission
denquête que pensez vous du fait que ce
soit exactement les mots qu'un employé
la garde des sceaux nicole belloubet ce
matin de commenter ainsi cette
commission dans quatre mois ajouté j'ai
pas entendu ce qu'a dit nicole belloubet
ce matin mais je corrobore on voit bien
que dans cette commission ce n'est pas
l'ex andré benalla qui est visé
d'ailleurs on interroge ce matin
membre du cabinet de l'élysée qui
n'était pas là au moment des fêtes qui
était en nouvelle calédonie qui était à
dix mille kilomètres
le nombre de réponses sur les événements
et en communication qui n'étaient pas là
on voit bien un petit peu le manque de
sérieux de l'opération en l'occurrence
moi je considère qu'on voit bien que la
commission du sénat se transforme en
juge en accusateurs en procureurs et
qu'elle cherche à travers cette affaire
plutôt atteint le président cas vraiment
faire la lumière sur une chose dont on
connaît tous aujourd'hui